see if thebes looks like fun but it's  not the first time banjo kazooie  developer rare has dabbled with pirates  in fact the team was working on a pirate  themed game before they created the  classic baron bert and for the first  time ever we have a chance to see that  game in action it was called dream and  it was originally meant to be a Super  Nintendo game before today this  screenshot was the only bit of the game  we'd seen now that rare has released  more footage we can see the original  hero edson doing its thing dream went  through many changes development shifted  from the SNES to the Nintendo 64 it  changed from a fantasy driven RPG like  Chrono Trigger to a pirate themed game  Edson eventually became banjo and his  dog became kazooie the game has lost to  time now but it's fun to look at footage  and wonder what could have been for now  the team continues to work on sea of  thieves to stay afloat with all the news  from rare keep yourself anchored at  GameSpot calm